more than two and a half years after
Gentry of this
of this the most prominent instigator of
the capital Riot from that day has
finally been arrested and charged with a
crime
years after other January sixth thirds
were convicted and served prison
sentences
friendly lectern enthusiasts Midwestern
grannies the whole gamut of January 6th
there's years after that the giant dude
who spent two days encouraging everyone
to storm the capital was finally
arrested and charged with uh
disorderly conduct
hmm
no seditious conspiracy charges
no terrorist enhancement charge
not even so much as a trespassing on
restricted grounds misdemeanor
and no explanation as to why Ray Epps
conspicuously uniquely perhaps was not
charged as U.S Marshals were sent to
round up just about everyone in the
proximity of the capital that day
wonder why that is let's review the tape
as soon as president Trump is finished
speaking we are going to the
Gap drop is just speaking we are going
through the capitol that's where our
problems
okay folks we need your help as soon as
president Trump stops speaking we are
going to the Capitol capital is in that
direction let people know spread the
word tomorrow we need to go into the
capitol into the capital
[Applause]
fed
Ah that's a theory fed fed fed Enrique
tario the leader of the proud boys was
was just arrested and charged and he's
going to face decades in prison for what
he wasn't even in Washington DC that day
he was in a hotel room in Baltimore but
prosecutors charged Enrique tario had
conspired to direct people to go into
the capital riot
well nobody directed people to go in and
ride in the capital more directly than
Ray Epps
and yet he gets a little disorderly
conduct charge slap on the wrist a few
years later so those guys are saying fed
fed fed sounds like a pretty compelling
Theory but
look this is America
and the accused are entitled to due
process so even if other conservatives
jump to conclusions I just want to say
for the record
I believe that special agent apps should
be presumed innocent until proven guilty
right now go to tommyjohn.com Knowles
listen this is a family show I don't
want to get too intimate with you here
but all I'm going to tell you is this
Tommy John makes the greatest boxer
shorts ever made period
when you get new
undergarments with Tommy John you will
also get 20 off your order with promo
code normal skin wlas their underwear
has dozens of comfort Innovations
breathable lightweight moisture wicking
fabric four times the stretch of
competing brands that can keep you much
cooler than cotton Tommy John also has
loungewear with a level of softness like
never before and is designed to envelop
you in a world of pure luxury every
purchase is backed by Tommy John's best
pair you'll ever wear or its free
guarantee I I'm not joking I didn't
realize Tommy John was coming back on
the show for reads I was thinking about
this just within the last few weeks I
pulled out a pair of Tommy Johns I
thought man these are just the greatest
boxers ever get 20 off your first order
right now tommyjohn.com Knowles
tommyjohn.com Knowles see site for
details go to
tommyjohn.com Knowles John fetterman is
not the least coherent national leader
in our nation's capital that I think
would have to go to Chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff Mark milley
who
though he's been accused of going woke
he he doesn't even know what that word
means is the US military to woke no not
at all um so
um you know I'm not even sure what that
word truly means but
um I would tell you that the military I
see is a military that's exceptionally
strong it's powerful it's ready in fact
our Readiness rates the way we measure
Readiness is better now I don't I don't
even know what that word means what are
you talking about woke you think we're
woke what on Earth what on Earth would
give you the impression that I mark
milley and woke
first of all
on the issue of critical race Theory Etc
a lobbyists have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is
um
but I do think it's important actually
for those of us in uniform to be
open-minded and be widely read and the
United States Military Academy is a
university and it is important that we
train and we understand uh and I want to
understand white rage
want to understand white rage I want to
understand critical race Theory
I wanna but I don't know what woke is
what are you talking about woke it's
just very important that every single
one of our Cadets read zebra Max candy
every day to understand the evil of
their whiteness
I believe for a fit fighting force we
must attend Robin D'Angelo seminars to
to become conscious of our unconscious
racial and sexual biases so that we no
longer
exert phobias on this world
I don't know what woke means
I'll tell you what woke means because
some conservatives have struggled to
explain what woke means to woke is just
the extreme conclusion of liberalism
that's all it is
and liberalism was famously once
described as uh the the liberal being
the man who can't take his own side in
an argument
that's what it is
it's the extreme conclusion
of an ideology predicated on a radical
individualism that culminates in
absurdity that is contrary to human
nature and to reality more broadly
that's what woke is
and as the US Military
adopts policies that contradict Human
Nature
in particular on one sexual matter that
we're not allowed to talk about on big
Tech I think you know the one I'm
talking about
as the US military decides to focus its
attention
and things like critical race Theory
rather than on killing our enemies
that would invert the purpose of that
institution make it much less ready to
fight and have it view the world in a
way that is contradictory to reality
I don't know what that means I'm gonna
have to read a little bit more
Kimberly Crenshaw then I'll understand
then we'll be a real fighting force boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
that you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles Show podcast see you
next time